foreign
so
so
so
foreign
please welcome mayor byron brown
[Applause]
we're here in the delavan grider
community center on the east side of
buffalo i want to thank
candace mappins the executive director
and the members of the board of
directors for hosting us today
beloved community as mayor of the city
of buffalo on behalf
of the more than 278 000 residents of
our
city
i want to just extend
our deepest and most heartfelt
condolences to the family members
of the
victims
of the vicious attack
on our community i want the family
members to know
that we love you
that we care about you and collectively
we are here to wrap our arms around you
and to help lift you up during this very
difficult
time
this is a time of great pain and sorrow
for all of us
in the city of buffalo
but
we are trusting
and leaning
on god
to get us through
this dark and difficult time
we are very thankful
that in the midst of this darkness
we have a president
and first lady
who care deeply
about our community and communities
all across the country
president joe biden
and first lady dr jill biden
are people with extraordinary
compassion and empathy
they wanted to be here for this
community
they wanted to help us
with our process of healing and we are
so thankful
that they are here with us
during this challenging time
as mayor it is my great honor and high
privilege to introduce our president joe
biden
and first lady dr joe biden
[Applause]
before i begin i joe would like to say a
few words
i just wanted to say uh
thank you to the families
uh for opening up your hearts to us
and for letting us be with you today
so god bless you and thank you for
allowing us to be with you
[Applause]
majority leader leader schumer and
senator gillibrand and congressman
higgins
and gov thank you for taking my call
when i called and
i forget what she said i said i'd like
to
maybe come up if it's okay she said
this is a big scranton come
come
and i have to do a heck of a job thank
you
thank you for your heart as well as your
head
mayor brown you've been uh you you've
been wonderful thank you and i know this
is a lot of
when the vice presidential or
presidential trip shows up it's uh
there's all kinds of
paraphernalian people and i know it's
not easy i want to thank your law
enforcement officers for not just what
they did
in this crisis but for accommodating us
and all the elected officials and
law enforcement officers first
responders
and faith leaders are here today
phil and i have come to stand with you
and to the families we've come to agree
with you
it's not the same but we know a little
bit what it's like to lose a piece of
your soul
which is a son or daughter husband wife
mother or father
the feeling of having that as i said to
some of you when we talk privately you
feel like there's a black hole in your
chest you're being sucked into and
you're suffocating unable to unable to
breathe that's what it felt like at
least to us and i'm sure
some version of that feels that way to
you
the anger
the pain
the depth of a loss that's so profound
you know we know it's hard to believe
and you're probably not going to believe
me but i can tell you now
from our personal experience and many
others who we've met
the day's going to come
it will come
when your loved one brings a smile as
you remember him or her
as you remember her it's going to bring
a smile to your lip before it brings a
tear to your eye
it takes a while for that to happen it
takes a while
might take more than a season
but our prayer for you is that that time
comes sooner or later but i promise you
it will come
as a nation
i say to the families we remember them
we've been reading about them
we visited the memorial where
the show
the love for them and you've all shown
by the supermarket
and uh
celestine cheney
65 years old
brain cancer survivor church goer
bingo player
went to buy strawberries to make her
favorite shortcake
a loving mother and a grandmother
roberta drury 32 beloved daughter and
sister
moved back home to help take care of her
brother after his bone marrow transplant
she went to buy groceries for dinner
the center of attention
who made everyone in the room laugh and
smile when she walked in
andre mcneil
excuse me andre mcneil
53
worked at a restaurant
went to buy his three-year-old son a
birthday cake
his son's selling a birthday
asking where's daddy
catherine massey 72
a writer and an advocate
who dressed up in costumes and schools
and cut the grass in the park and
helping local elections
the glue of the family and the community
marcus morrison 52 school bus aide
went to buy snacks for a weekly movie
night of the family
survived by his wife and three children
and his stepdaughter
the center of their world
hayward patterson 67
father
church deacon
fed the homeless
at soup kitchen
gave rides to the grocery store to
neighbors who needed help
putting food in the trunk of others
when he took his final breath
aaron solder 55 retired buffalo police
officer
for three decades
three decades
loved electric cars
hero gave his life to save others on a
saturday afternoon
and had that man not been wearing that
vest that he purchased bulletproof vest
a lot of lies would have been saved
a beloved father
and husband
geraldine talley 62
expert banker and known for her warm
gentle personality
a friend everybody devoted mother and
grandmother
ruth whitfield
88
beloved
wife mother grandmother great
grandmother
sang in the church choir
a caretaker of her husband bringing him
clean clothes cutting his hair holding
his hand every day she visited him in
the nursing home
heart as big as her head
pearl young 77 a mother grandmother
missionary of god
public school teacher
who also ran the local food pantry
loves singing dancing and her family
and all three are injured so you're
goodman 20.
shot in the neck but fighting through it
jennifer warrington 50 christopher
braden 55
both treated with injuries on a long
road to recovery
individual lives of love service and
community
that speaks to the bigger story of who
we are as americans
a great nation
because we're good people
jill and i bring you this message from
deep
in our nation's
soul in america evil will not win i
promise you
hate will not prevail
and white supremacy
will not have the last word
for the
evil did come to buffalo
has come to all too many places
manifest in gunmen who massacred
innocent people
in the name of hateful and perverse
ideology
rooted in fear and racism
it's taken so much
ten lives cut short in a grocery store
three other wounds three or three other
wounded by a hate-filled individual who
had driven 200 miles from binghamton in
their
range
to carry out a murderous racist rampage
that he would live stream
live stream to the world
what happened here is simple and
straightforward terrorism
terrorism
domestic terrorism
violence inflicted in the service of
hate
and the vicious thirst for power that
defines one group of people
being inherently inferior to any other
group
a hate
that through the media
and politics the internet
has radicalized angry alienated lost and
isolated individuals into falsely
believing
that they will be replaced that's the
word replaced
by the other
by people who don't look like them
and who are therefore
in the perverse ideology that they
possess and being fed lesser beings
i and all of you reject the lie
i call on all americans to reject the
lie and i condemn those
who spread the lie for power
political gain
and for profit
that's what it is
we've now seen too many times the deadly
and destructive violence this ideology
unleashes
we heard the chance
you will not replace us in
charlottesville virginia
i wasn't going to run as the senator
knows
again for president
when i saw those people
coming out of the woods of the fields in
virginia in charlottesville carrying
torches
shouting you will not replace us
accompanied by white supremacists and
carrying nazi banners
that's when i said no
no and i honest to god those who know me
chuck you know i wasn't going to run for
certain
but i was going to be darned if i was
going to let anyway
i'll get going
look we've seen the mass shootings in
charleston south carolina el paso texas
and pittsburgh
last year in atlanta
this week in dallas texas and now in
buffalo
buffalo new
york white supremacy is a poison
it's a poison
running through it really is
running through our body politic
and it's been allowed to fester and grow
right in front of our eyes
no more
i mean no more
we need to say as clearly and forced as
we can
that the ideology of white supremacy has
no place in
america
none
[Applause]
look
fairly for us to not say that failure is
saying that there's going to be
complicity silence is complicity
it's complicity we cannot remain silent
our nation's strength has always come
from the idea
this can sound corny but think about it
what's the idea of our nation
we're all children of god
all life liberty
are universal goods
gifts of god we didn't get it from a
government we got it from because we
exist
called upon to defend them
the venom of the haters
and their weapons of war
the violence and the words and deeds of
the
that stalk our streets our stores our
schools
this venom this violence cannot be the
story of our time
we cannot allow that to happen
look i'm not naive
i know tragedy will come again
it cannot be forever overcome
it cannot be fully understood either
but there are certain things we can do
we can keep assault weapons off our
streets
we've done it before
i did it when he passed a crime bill
last time and violence went down
shootings went down
you can't prevent people from being
radicalized to violence
but we can't address the relentless
exploitation of the internet to recruit
and mobilize terrorism
we just need to have the courage to do
that to stand up
look the american experiment
in democracy
is in a
danger like it hasn't been in my
lifetime
it's an endangered this hour
hate and fear of being given too much
oxygen
by those who pretend to love america
but who don't understand
america to confront the ideology of hate
requires
caring about all people
not making distinctions
reverend the scripture
is seen that we're all part of the
divine
love thy neighbor as thyself
that's the america i know that jill
knows
and most deserve the most we just look
we're the most multi-racial most dynamic
nation in history of the world
now is the time
for the people of all races
from every background
to speak up as a majority in american
and reject white supremacy
these actions
we've seen
in these hate-filled attacks
represent the views of a hate-filled
minority
we can't allow them to distort america
the real america
we can't allow them to destroy the soul
of the nation
as president united states i travel the
world
all the time
and other nations ask me heads of state
in other countries
ask me
what's going
on what in god's name happened on
january 6 what happened in buffalo what
happened to ask
we have to refuse to live in a country
where black people going about a weekly
grocery shopping can be gunned down by
weapons of war
deployed
in a racist cause
we have to refuse to live in a country
where fear and lies are packaged for
power and for profit
we must all enlist
in this great cause of america
this is work that requires all of us
presidents politicians commentators
citizens
none of us can stay in the sidelines
we have to resolve that here in buffalo
that from the tragedy this tragedy will
come hope and light and life
it has to
that on our watch
the sacred cause of america will never
bow never break never bend
the american we love the one we love
will endure
so to the families
from your pain
may we find purpose
to live life worthy of the loved ones
you lost
from a hymn
based on the 91st psalm the song of my
church
may he raise you up on eagle's wings and
bear you on the breath of dawn
make you to shine like the sun
and hold you in the palm of his hand
that's my for us
we can do this if we resolve to do it
if we take on the haters
and those who don't even care it's just
about profit
and politics
may the soul
of the fallen
rest in peace
and rise in glory
and may god guide the united states of
america
now and always
to the
families my grandpa used to say when i
walked out of his home in scranton he'd
say joey
spread the faith
and my grandmother y'all know joey i
mean he said keep the faith my
grandmother said no joe he spread the
faith
we're thinking of you hold on each other
tightly
stick together you'll get through this
it will make buffalo and the united
states a better place to live than it is
today
[Applause]
hmm
nice
so
okay
[Applause]
you